welcome everyone this is part five in
our series on contextual word
representations we're going to be
talking about the electra model electra
stands for efficiently learning an
encoder that classifies token
replacements accurately which is a
helpfully descriptive breakdown of a
colorfully named model
recall that i finished the bert
screencast by identifying some known
limitations of the burp model
elektra is really keying into two and
three in that list so the second one
identified by the bert authors is just
that of the mlm objective they say we're
creating a mismatch between pre-training
and fine-tuning since the mask token
that we use is never seen during fine
tuning so ideally for the model we
fine-tuned we would make no use of a
mass token
devlin and i'll also observe on the of
the mlm objective that it has a downside
we make predictions about only 15 of the
tokens in each batch
we have an intuition that that's a
pretty inefficient use of the data we
have available to us ideally we would
make more predictions and elektra seeks
to make good on that intuition as well
so let's dive into the core model
structure here we'll use a simple
example we have an input token sequence
x the chef cooked the meal
and as usual with bert we can mask out
some of those tokens and then have a
burp or bert like model try to
reconstruct those mask tokens however
we're going to do that with a twist
instead of always trying to learn the
actual input token we're going to sample
tokens proportional to the generator
probabilities so that sometimes the
actual token will be input as with the
case without here and sometimes it will
be some other token as the case with
cooked going to eight in this position
now the job of electra the discriminator
here is to figure out which of those
tokens were in the original input
sequence and which have been replaced so
that's a binary prediction task and we
can make it about all of the tokens in
our input sequence if we choose to
the actual loss for
electra is the sum of the generator loss
and a weighted version of the electra
that is the discriminator loss however
that's kind of masking an important
asymmetry in this model here
once we have trained the generator we
can let it fall away and do all of our
fine-tuning on the discriminator that is
on electra itself which means that we'll
be fine-tuning a model that never saw
any of those mask tokens so we addressed
that first limitation of bert and we're
also going to make a prediction with
with elektra about every single one of
the input tokens which means that we're
making more use of the available data
one thing i really like about the
electra paper is that it offers a really
rich set of analyses of the efficiency
of the model and of its optimal design
so i'm going to highlight some of those
results here starting with this
generator discriminator relationship
result
so the authors observe that where the
generator and discriminator are the same
size
they can share all their transformer
parameters they can kind of be one model
in essence and they find that more
sharing is indeed better which is
encouraging
however they also observe that the best
results coming come from having a
generator that is small compared to the
discriminator and this plot kind of
summarizes the evidence there so
uh we have our glue score as the goal
post that we're going to use to assess
these models that's along the y-axis
along the x-axis we have the generator
size and then we've plotted out a few
sizes for the discriminator and i think
what you can see quite clearly is that
in general you get the best results on
glue where the discriminator is two to
three times larger than the generator
and that's true even for this very small
modeling green down here the results are
overall not very good but we see that
same relationship where the optimal
discriminator is at size 256
and the generator at size 64. that's
where we reach our peak results and
that's kind of comparable to this very
large model in blue where optimal size
for the discriminator is 768 compared to
256 for the generator
they also do a bunch of really
interesting efficiency analyses one
thing i like about the paper is that
it's kind of oriented toward figuring
out how we can train these models more
efficiently with fewer compute resources
and this is a kind of summary of central
evidence that they offer that electra
can be an efficient model so again we're
going to use along the y-axis the glue
score as our goal post but along the
x-axis here we have pre-training flop so
this would be the number of compute
operations that you need to pre-train
the model
in blue along the top here is electra
it's the very best model
in orange just below it is adversarial
electra
which is an interesting approach to
electra where we essentially train the
generator to try to fool the
discriminator as opposed to having the
two cooperate as in core electro and
that turns out to be pretty good and
also these green lines are really
interesting so
two-stage electra is where i start by
training just against the bert objective
and at a certain point switch over to
training the electro objective and you
can see that even that is better than
just continuing on with bert all the way
up to the maximum for our compute budget
here
the paper also explores a bunch of
variations on the electra objective
itself so i presented to you full
electra and it's full electra in the
sense that over here on the right we're
making predictions about every single
one of the tokens in the input
we could also explore something that was
analogous to bird electra 15 would be
the case where we make predictions only
about tokens that were way back here in
the input x mass actually masked out
another variant that the team considered
actually relates to how we train birds
so recall that for bert we train both by
masking and by replacing some tokens
with other randomly chosen tokens and we
could try training the generator just
with that approach which would eliminate
the mass token entirely so that's this
variant here where we have no masking on
x-max masked but rather just randomly
replace tokens from the actual
vocabulary
and then finally all tokens mlm would
adopt some ideas from electra into the
burp model so recall that for the mlm
objective we essentially turned it off
for tokens that weren't masked but
there's no principle reason why we're
doing that we could of course have the
loss applied to every single one of the
tokens in the input stream and that
gives us all tokens mlm on the generator
side
the central finding of the paper i
suppose is that electra is the best of
all of these models you also have a
really good model if you do all tokens
mlm which is something that might inform
development on the burt side
in addition to burp in the context of
electro
replace mlm is less good and electric 15
kind of down there at the bottom near
bur i think this is kind of showing us
that we should make more predictions
that was a guiding intuition for electra
and it seems to be borne out by these
results
and finally uh as is common in this
space the electric team did some model
releases of pre-trained parameters that
you can make use of they did electro
bass and electrolarge which are kind of
comparable to the corresponding burp
releases i think an interesting thing
they did is also released this burp this
electric small model which is designed
to quickly be trained on a single gpu
again tying into the idea that we ought
to be thinking about how we can train
models like this when we have highly
constrained compute resources electro is
keyed into that idea from the very
beginning i think the small model shows
that it can be productive